dr seymour tracy is an ordinary american
man
he lives in a two-bedroom home with a
white picket fence
in an ordinary suburban town in the
midwest
he gets up every day and goes to work
then
in the evening he comes home to spend
time with his family
from the outside seymour and his family
couldn't be
more normal but in reality there's
something very abnormal about him
his life and the neighborhood where he
lives
seymour tracy isn't just some office
worker he's a researcher employed by the
scp
foundation just like all of his
neighbors
because this isn't an ordinary
neighborhood it's a functioning site-11
satellite facility bought and maintained
by the foundation for the sole purpose
of containing and monitoring
a single scp scp-3082
scp-3082 is an ordinary treehouse
two meters by two meters in size and
built from ordinary
cherry wood planks and it's located in
one of the trees in the neighborhood
park
you might expect that an anomaly that
requires an entire suburb of people to
monitor it is exceptionally difficult to
contain
but the truth is scp-3082
is only a euclid-class anomaly fairly
tame by foundation standards
the fact that the houses surrounding
this scp are inhabited solely by
foundation personnel and their families
is
more than anything a way to keep up
appearances of this being a completely
normal neighborhood
unlike most foundation sites the
personnel working in this unorthodox
setup around
scp-3082 are mostly researchers
and their work is just as much
anthropological and diplomatic
as it is scientific as you might have
guessed
scp-3082 isn't a normal tree house on
the inside
open up the small hatch in the wall and
step through
and you'll find yourself in a much
larger grander tree house
that rests on the upper branches of an
absolutely
massive conifer-like tree of an
unidentified species
the tree designated as scp-3082-1 is an
incredible 160 kilometers tall
and while its own species is not known
it appears to have multiple recognizable
plants grafted onto
and growing out of its bark many of
these plants are fruit bearing and in
addition to the identifiable plants
there are also a number of pitcher
plant-like flowers that collect and hold
fresh water
these plants serve as sustenance for the
only known inhabitants of
scp-3082 a colony of around
74 children all between the ages of 4
and 12. these children live in a village
made up of other tree houses built among
the branches of
scp-3082-1 and all of them match the
descriptions of children from around the
united states who went missing between
1996
and the present day curiously within
scp-3082's pocket dimension
the children don't physically age and
while foundation personnel
can move freely back and forth through
the hatch in scp-3082's wall
children under the age of 13 are unable
to cross back through once inside the
pocket dimension
it's a very extraordinary anomaly but it
was up to the very ordinary dr
tracy to make contact with the residents
of scp-3082
upon entering he discovered that the
children had formed their own system of
government
known as the chief royal council dr
tracy was introduced to many of the
council's members
including wexley olsen age six a junior
council member
lucy fujimoto age seven who had taken
the role of city planner and resource
manager
ahmed saeed age 11 who served as a
caretaker to the younger citizens of
scp-3082
and rachel jeffries age 10 who acted as
a council mediator
through interviews with the subjects dr
tracy found that all 74 of the children
reported they had woken
up on the porch of a tree house after
running away from troubled homes
most of the council members had
disappeared in 1996
except for olsen who disappeared in
2005.
older residents reported that some of
the treehouse that make up what is now
their village were already there upon
their discovery of the pocket dimension
also pre-existing within the pocket
dimension was the original leader of the
chief royal council
a twelve-year-old girl from ohio named
arya morrison
the foundation was eager to speak to
morrison as she was seemingly the first
child to discover
scp-3082 but when dr tracy asked the
other children
where she was they told him that they
didn't know
according to saeed and jeffries morrison
abandoned the colony five months before
the foundation's arrival
it was unclear where she could have gone
as drone exploration conducted by the
foundation revealed that scp-3082-1 was
the only large living thing for miles
within the pocket dimension
while the tree was thriving the
surrounding area was mostly flat
decaying and barren further research
into morrison's history showed that her
younger sister
jacqueline morrison had also gone
missing on the same night
but there was no evidence that jaclyn
had ever entered
as cp 3082 the foundation conducted
their research
into the biology of scp-3082-1
while maintaining diplomatic relations
with the pocket dimension
citizens taking advantage of the fact
that adults could move freely
in and out of the hatch the foundation
started working with the chief royal
council to improve the weight limits on
the village systems of rope bridges
as well as providing any supplies that
the children might need
such as additional food clothing and
medical equipment
these liaisons were extremely helpful
for the children
many of whom had been without adult
supervision or care for over a decade
saeed for one example had fallen off of
a bridge and broken his leg several
years earlier
and had been living with the pain caused
from the bone being incorrectly set
ever since however there was an
unexpected side effect of this continued
contact
while the foundation tried to remain
neutral in their involvement in the
policies of 3082
through dr tracy's interviews he
discovered that the scp foundation's
presence in the treehouse had caused a
schism within the chief royal council
the vast majority of the children
including saeed
jeffries and fujimoto supported the
foundation's presence
and wanted to work with them to find a
way to leave the world of 3082
and return back to what the children
call the real world
but a splinter group had developed
calling themselves the neverland
movement
the neverland movement were angered by
the foundation's interference
and intended to resist any attempt to
return the children to civilization
olson had become the de facto leader of
the splinter group
and made no secrets about his views on
the foundation he swore at tracy during
interviews
and frequently butted heads with the
rest of the council fujimoto in
particular
at one point tracy overheard the two of
them fighting with olsen arguing that
neverland gives them
everything they need without any
grown-ups to tell them what to do
and that they would be stupid to give
that up to which fujimoto responded
i was here back when we were still
building the village i was here before
we had safety nets
ladders and fences and before we figured
out how to build a tree house that
wouldn't fall apart if someone leaned on
a bad wall
i was here before we knew where there
was more food if we needed it
when did you get here huh after we knew
what we were doing
listening to the conversation dr tracy
heard the children refer again to arya
morrison in a way that suggested that
she had some kind of control over the
environment
in reference to the incident where saeed
had broken his leg fujimoto said
mary didn't fix his leg right and this
place didn't fix it either
arya prayed and you know what happened
nothing
from this comment the foundation started
to theorize that arya had somehow been
involved in the creation of scp-3082
and arya was officially designated as
scp-3082-2
one morning when dr tracy entered the
treehouse and walked through the hatch
to conduct further interviews
he was greeted by olson who was the only
child in the main tree house at the time
tracy asked what was wrong and olson
explained that the tree had started to
change
a wooden slide had appeared between two
of the tree's fruit-bearing branches
snapping the rope bridge and making the
fruit more difficult to access
on top of that olsen said that the
apples the trees produced were different
now
they look like apples from the outside
but now seem to be made of cotton candy
on the inside
dr tracy put in a request for
non-perishable foods to be sent through
into the pocket dimension fearing that
further changes to the tree structure
would mean the children would be
deprived of enough proper nutrition to
survive
given these changes it became apparent
that more had to be done to understand
the tree's physiology
an exploratory drone was sent into the
dimension with cameras and sensors
collecting data on the lower parts of
the tree that the children hadn't
colonized
the expedition continued as normal until
the drone operator spotted
a hollow in the tree that had not yet
been documented
the cameras detected movement inside the
hollow and on closer inspection
the operators were shocked to find it
was a person
more specifically it was arya morrison
the cameras were only just able to
confirm her identity though
as the drone was knocked out of the sky
by a falling watermelon
and the feed was cut before the request
for a replacement drone could even be
approved though
the broken drone started transmitting
again in front of the camera was
morrison
clutching a roll of duct tape she
explained to the camera that she'd
rewired the drone to resume the camera
feed and remove some of the drones fan
blades
using a system where the operators of
the drone would rotate the remaining
blades once for yes
and twice for no the foundation was able
to hold a conversation with morrison
she confirmed much of the information
that the foundation already had on her
that she was from ohio and that she and
her sister jacqueline had disappeared in
1996.
during the conversation morrison wrote
down a morris code-like system through
which to communicate
more complex questions and answers and
with the help of this
morrison code the foundation was able to
conduct a series of more
in-depth interviews with the subject the
first interview occurred 44 hours after
first making contact
and the drone operators explained to her
the nature of the scp foundation in
basic terms
they assured her that the other children
were still safe in the village
but morrison didn't volunteer any more
information about herself
nine days later though she finally told
the foundation her story
arya and jacqueline morrison had a
difficult childhood together
their parents fought constantly and
would often leave their sisters at home
without supervision for long periods of
time
jaclyn perhaps aided by all the time she
spent alone displayed an extremely
active imagination
so active in fact that arya claimed she
was able to pull things out of thin
air warping reality around her to fit
her
imagined scenarios arya recalled that
one year when the morrison parents had
forgotten jaclyn's birthday
arya tried to comfort her by saying that
the family had been planning a surprise
party for jaclyn's half birthday instead
she forgot all about the white lie until
six months later
when the girl's parents took them to the
park and everything arya had told
jacqueline would be
at her half birthday was there waiting
for them
knowing the potential consequences of
letting jaclyn's power go unchecked
arya always made sure to remind her
sister to turn things back to normal
after they played pretend together one
night in 1996
while their parents were having a
particularly bad fight the sisters
packed a bag and ran
off into the woods after about half an
hour they got turned around
but they kept walking just as afraid of
what would happen to them if they went
back home
as they were of being lost in the woods
arya lost track of jaclyn for a moment
and suddenly found herself standing on
the porch of scp-3082
unable to find jaclyn anywhere arya
searched the treehouse
and in the process became trapped in
scp-3082's pocket dimension
the tree house inside the pocket
dimension appeared exactly as it does
now
but the rest of the tree was devoid of
life
scared alone and running out of water
arya sat in the tree house and
pretending that her sister was with her
started telling a bedtime story about
fruit trees and pictures of fresh water
the next day she awoke to find a system
of rope bridges
and a grove where scp-3882-1's fruit
fruit-bearing trees and pitcher plants
had sprouted overnight
arya found that when it was in a giving
mood the tree would respond to any
requests she made
more children started to appear over
time and they started making additions
to the village with the trees help
they would get what they needed to
survive but the tree refused to let them
go
in arya morrison's own words jaclyn
likes it too much here in neverland
i think jackie might listen better if i
get closer to the part of her that
remembers
but for now she doesn't hear me when i
say it's time to go home
trees don't really think like people do
and so
the children continue to live in the
world of scp-3082 to this day
as a whole town of scp foundation
personnel work to bring them back
and hopefully if they are able to return
to the real world
they'll find it's the world they deserve
now go check out scp-087 the staircase
and scp-096 the shy guy for more
and don't forget to subscribe and turn
on notifications to be the first to
learn about the fascinating files from
the scp foundation